The movie so good I’ve seen it 6 times
Aquaman turns mountain man!
Michael Shannon gets paranoid
Hello, and welcome to Indie Movie Guide
I am Alicia and I cannot sing!
Yeah, I shouldn’t give up my day job
But this week in the theaters
I can live by curiously through Emma Stone and Ryan Gosling
and live out my fantasies of being in a musical by watching ‘La La Land’
I’m gonna tell you all about that film coming up soon
but first... let’s start off with a little psycho-sexual drama, shall we?
In theaters and on video on demand this week you can catch a movie called ‘Frank & Lola’
and I encourage you to seek it out
It stars Michael Shannon and Imogen Poots
and it’s all about a relationship that turns very paranoid
Clip: -You really look out for me, I’m not used to it
-Well, get used to it
-Every morning when I wake up, first thing I think of is you
-You fall in love usually Frank?
So, Frank is a talented chef, but even then he’s not quite sure he is good enough for Lola
the flighty fashion designer, and that insecurity spills out into something quite dark.
Now this movie is best when it looks at the complexity of relationships
particularly from the male perspective
It does go a little bit out there with the plot
but the person that grounds it all is Michael Shannon
I cannot believe how good he is on every single film
Just think about this year alone
He’s been in ‘Midnight Special’
He was in that small but important part of ‘Loving’
‘Nocturnal animals’ for what he probably will get a Best Supporting Actor Nomination at the Oscars
I hope he does, and now ‘Frank & Lola’
That plus the cinematography
and the way it looks at relationships through the psychological thriller lens
is the reason why you should try to see ‘Frank & Lola’
*Clip* -No man should be expose to that
-I love you
-Me too
Another smaller film that you should try to seek out if possible it’s called 'Sugar Mountain'
This is another twisted drama about two brothers who decide to fake a missing person in the mountain story
so they can sell that story to the media, make some money, pay off their debts
and also pay off this thug who is after them played by Jason Momoa
*Clip* -Caught you little runt!
-I want the money
-10,000 bucks
-We need cash
-You know… and fast
The plot of ‘Sugar Mountain’ moves at a really great pace
and the brothers get a lot more trouble that they bargain for when they go on this venture
And… Jason Momoa...
he uses his huge physique, in full force
to be this very scary thug, which is exactly what that role needed
-It’s a hoax
-Pardon me?
-A hoax
It’s also shot beautifully and very entertaining
So try to seek out ‘Sugar Mountain’ if it is playing near you this weekend
If it’s not, I’m sure it is gonna be on video on demand very soon.
*Clip* -Hope for finding the young man alive is decreasing…
-Who has said again that there’s no evidence of foul play in the disappearance.
Now to the film I might possibly be addicted to, because I’ve seen it 6 times
Actually I’m pretty sure that I am addicted to it
I’m talking about ‘La La Land’ and when you see this movie...
if you know me at all
you will understand why I love it so much
Because ‘La La Land’ is an ode to classic musicals
It’s an ode to classic movies
It’s about Los Angeles
it’s about chasing your hopes, ambitions, and dreams…
Also love, and the choices we make and how those choices affect you in the future
and it also stars my favorite Emma Stone
*Clip* -Maybe I’m not good enough
-Yes, you are
-Maybe I’m not
-It’s like a pipe dream
-This is the dream.
It’s conflict and it’s compromise
it’s very, very exciting
Big awards watch on this one!
Possible Oscar nominations for Best Picture, for Best Lead Actress for Emma Stone
Best Lead Actor for Ryan Gosling
Best Director for Damien Chazelle
Best Production Design
Best Score, Best Song
So many more!
It’ll probably sweep most of the awards this Award season
and it definitely deserves to
It’s a bloody joy to watch
it looks beautiful, it will hit you in the feels
Everyone can relate to this
It's got great songs and dance numbers
Have I convince you yet?
If not, here is our modern day…
Ryan Gosling and Emma Stone to tell you more
-I love this movie so much, as someone who grew up watching classic musicals
and dreaming of moving to L.A…
I know you didn’t just make it for me, but it feels like you did.
-You’re welcomed.
It was just for you actually, that’s the secret.
-This is all just for me, I appreciated.
-After doing this film with something you have to be out of your comfort zone for
Do you feel more fearless in a way about movies in general?
-I had such an incredibly deep experience doing it
because when you put so much of yourself in something and you rehearse for so long…
you really give... you know, you give it your all.
I just fell in love with that element of the process
-I would’ve thought it would be hard to look indignant while wearing yellow 80’ pants
but you pull that off pretty well.
-Just wanted to say that
-Thank you
-What do you relate to with the character of Sebastian?
Or was there something in particular that you loved about him?
-I love the time in his life that you meet him in the film
because he’s experienced a lot of failure and rejection…
and he is right on the coast of becoming a very angry, bitter, person
which is the worst time to meet somebody, a potential love interest
but that’s the way it happens in the movie.
-Congratulations!
-Nice jazz hands
So… with ‘La La Land’ now in theatres my Top 5 looks like this:
My top best movies are:
Moonlight, Manchester by the sea, La La Land
Arrival, Nocturnal Animals…
Sorry Lion, Lion still fantastic but it just goes down a step or two…
and so many more movies coming out towards the end of the year
so I’m sure it will change once again
I know I’m gonna get a lot of comments like:
Why you love ‘La La Land’ so much but it’s not your number one?
Hard to explain, but I think I look at these as the best made movies
and I just thought ‘Moonlight’ was something I’d never seen before
Here’s what I see for the top 10 contenders for the Best Picture nominees:
Arrival, Fences, Jackie, Hacksaw Ridge, if they’re ready to forgive Mel Gibson and they should
La La Land, Lion, Loving, Moonlight, Manchester by the sea
and Silence by Martin Scorsese…
Silence it’s the only one on this that I haven’t seen yet
but it’s getting good buzz from the few screening that it had so far.
To recap once again what you can see this weekend:
Check out ‘La La Land’ in theatres
if it’s not playing near you right now it will be expanding in the next few weeks
Also in theatres and on VOD make sure you catch ‘Frank & Lola’
and try to see ‘Sugar Mountain’ in theatres
Once again that will  probably be on video on demand later on…
so don’t fret if it’s not in your area just yet
That’s the end for another Fandango Indie Movie Guide
Let me know in the comments below what you think of this week’s movies
What you think of ‘La La Land’, whether I hyped this movie up way too much
I probably have, but I don’t care I’m gonna go see it for a 7th time
and I’ll see you next week. Bye!
I’m just rumbling now so, shut up Alicia!